i just saw
the most
pathetic
magnificent
absurd
transparent display
of
incompetent almost certainly corrupt
government
maybe i've ever seen
this came yesterday
not from some foreign government that
came from our government
came from the state department it turns
out there's at least one actual
journalist one actual reporter left in
washington
the state department is trying to
ratchet up tensions with russia
over this issue of ukraine
and they've been trying a number of
different strategies to do this and
yesterday the state department and state
department spokesman what's his name ned
price made this claim that russia is
going to launch a false flag attack
that will then give them
a pretext to invade ukraine and the
reporter in the room had a very simple
question
only one reporter he said what is your
evidence and the state department
couldn't answer
what we know matt is what we what i have
just said that they have engaged in this
activity
in this planning activity
but let me let me because because
obviously this is not this is not the
first time we've made uh
these reports public you'll remember
that just a few weeks ago sorry you
made what report public
if you let me finish i will tell you
what report we made public uh we told
you a few weeks ago that we have
information indicating russia also has
already pre-positioned a group of
operatives to conduct a false flag
operation in eastern ukraine so that
matt to your question is an action that
russia has already taken it's an action
that you say that they have taken but
you have shown no evidence to
to confirm that and i'm going to get to
the next question here which is what is
the evidence that they i mean this is
like crisis actors really this is like
alex jones territory you're getting into
now
um what evidence do you have to support
the idea that there is some propaganda
film in the in in the making
hold on i've got to pause it there it
only gets better the state department
only clowns itself further the reason i
have to pause it though is the reporter
did make a mistake he said that the
state department is getting into alex
jones territory that is not true alex
jones is much more trustworthy than the
state department
alex jones has a much better record of
predictions than the state department
including the gay frogs he was right
about the gay frogs okay and it's not i
am damning with faint praise a little
bit here because the state department
and our federal bureaucracy and the
liberal establishment has such a
terrible record that the reporter is
saying you're asking me to just take
this on faith that you're telling me the
truth but you guys are incompetent and
liars so why am i supposed to believe
you
matt this is derived from information
known to the us government intelligence
information that we have declassified i
think okay well where where is it where
where is this information it is
intelligence information that we have
declassified well where is it where is
the declassified information i just
delivered it
no you made a series of allegations
would you would you like us to print out
the topper because you will see a
transcript of this briefing that you can
print out for yourself it's not evidence
ned that's you saying it that's not
evidence i'm sorry
what would you like matt
i i would like to see some proof
i'd like some proof no well i'm giving
it to you
okay let's try this again mr state
department spokesman
what is the evidence that that
russia is going to launch a false flag
and that's why we need to go send a
zillion troops to ukraine and start a
war with russia what is the evidence
that that's going to happen
well i just gave it to you
no you made an allegation yeah that's
right that's the evidence
i said so take my word for it take my
word for it
take my word for it
the people
who have lied about
and or screwed up
every major foreign policy issue
almost for my entire lifetime
the fall of the berlin wall was the last
thing that the and actually they didn't
get that right either reagan was right
about the fall of the berlin wall and
the state department and those people
all tried to screw it up so actually
never mind forget that they've
these people have screwed up every
major foreign policy issue almost
without exception
for as far back as i can even remember
with historical memory
the people who told us that sanam
hussein was making nukes the people who
told us that kabul was not going to
forget about we have to go back to
ancient history with saddam and the
nukes what about kabul what about the
afghanistan debacle from a year ago we
were told
less than a year ago
we were told
that kabul was not going to fall it was
strong the afghan national government
was great it fell within weeks
with days
but trust us we're right
believe us give me a break bro
sorry i'm not even denying that that
vladimir putin would stage a false flag
the guy's capable of doing just about
anything
he's a former kgb agent who runs russia
and wants to greatly expand russia's
territory and has already invaded
russia's neighbors so i'm not saying he
wouldn't do it sure of course he could
do it
but but i ain't just taking the state
department's word for it
or the the rest of the federal blob i
just
they've squandered their credibility
they don't have credibility anymore and
that's not my fault
it's not it's not unpatriotic it's not
conspiratorial
it's not
irrational not to believe these people
after they've gotten everything wrong
and lied to us for decades you want you
want us to go invade ukraine ned price
you want us to go start a war with
russia okay fine show me the proof of
these things though
don't just tell me to take your word for
it because
your word and a buck 50 used to get you
a cup of coffee now you need 350 to get
a cup of coffee because of joe biden's
inflation
did you like that clip i'm glad ring the
bell please that way you'll get
notifications and then because sometimes
you don't get notifications head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we will see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you